work you hate Ron right no I think Ron
is fine so we're on the same page you
gotta help me take this guy down there's
got to be something on him
Tom I'm starting to feel kind of gross
about this game it's not about the game
anymore Ron had some serious dirt on me
I need to balance things out you must
know how that feels
he got tons of dirt in your past please
you got to help me there is a man named
Duke silver he hangs out at a bar in
Eagleton he's an old friend of Ron's
maybe you should ask him thanks man
I can't dig up so much dirt on this guy
there's gonna be worms all over the
place it sounded snap here in my head
yeah hey this is gonna sound weird I'm
looking for a guy named Duke silver oh
yeah he was on in a second ladies ladies
ladies it's just about that time is with
the chassis especially that I bring out
for you my man mr. Duke silver
thank you doing as always it is a thrill
to be here during this witching hour
with you lovely ladies now relax and let
the Duke silver trio take you on a
little journey to yourself
[Music]
it's been a real gift making sonic level
to you do you want more of the Duke both
my albums are for sale hair smooth the
silver and I hope do you look for my new
CD next month memories of now so come
see me come talk to me come love with me
and maybe we can walk through the fire
together thank you good night Duke huge
fan look Tom I imagine you'll want to
tell everyone about this but I have
worked pretty hard to cultivate a
certain authoritative or intimidating
image around the office take a picture
sure say I bested you I bested you
alright thanks for loving them dude yeah
that was a lovely hotel truce truce well
hello there you must be Ron Swanson Oh
welcome to Casa blood gate
hello mr. Lovegood ah call me Larry
Susie's boss Oh rolling
Rita Ludd gate oh you have no idea how
nice it is to meet you oh come in for
God's sake what can I get you to drink
Oh could you take your shoes off please
thank you so much nothing to drink
Thanks Oh April around Zuzu you have a
guest
I'll fetch her she's probably on I'll
come with you
you make yourself at home mr. Swanson
thank you
you must be April's sister I'm Ron mmm
mr. major why are you here come back to
work no come back I want you to come
back well I don't want to come back the
end I was talking to Andy about you and
he made me realize that I need you back
at work what did he say don't recall
fine I'll come back good ok I'm leaving
bye Zuzu bye
Duke silver my mom has all your albums I
recognized you the day we met have you
told anyone no good girl
Studios down here let's go hustle people
come on Jerry that's vandalism I have a
problem this happens to be the studio
where a local saxophone legend named
Duke silver records his albums I've
heard of him I heard he makes mature
women swoon when he plays from what I've
heard about Duke he's kind of a private
guy he doesn't want his nosy co-workers
discussing his music with him or knowing
that he exists so if you happen to see
any memorabilia laying around kindly and
discreetly discarded you got it Duke
don't call me that
take your goofy chance man did you hear
me I said I dig your groovy tunes man I
never thought I'd say this to you son
but you may be overthinking this song
has to be perfect wrong okay Leslie
trusted me with it I can't come up with
some brilliant political idea can I this
is the only way I can help maybe if I
have my head against around that's
worked before Leslie is gonna love it I
promise
no offense Ron but what do you know
about music hey take a walk clear your
head I bet it does you some good
alright guys here's a deal we got a
completely start over I wrote a new song
it's called the promise of tomorrow's
wings
it's brilliant about a billion times
better than catch your dreams which I
realize now sucks ass hey Chuck go ahead
and just delete everything all right
hold on Chuck just listen to the song
one more time and then make a decision
[Music]
where's that saxophone coming from I
don't know I don't know the first thing
about music
oh is that a new mix sounds way better
she just needed to clear your head hey
guys so let'slet's this looks just like
wow that was loud
she just knows you so well I was
starting to wonder if I was ever gonna
get to that point I'm worried that maybe
there isn't room in your life for
another woman at this very moment Leslie
is throwing herself in front of a
freight train named Tammy for me and you
Leslie is a wonderful loyal friend who
was very important in my life but I
would sooner visit Europe then I have
something romantic happen between us
although if you'd like to visit Europe I
like you so much I'd be willing to risk
it but not France right god no see you
know me pretty well already but you're
about to get to know me even better I
brought you here because I want to show
you something
that almost no one knows about certainly
not Tammy and not even Leslie no ladies
until and especially the ladies put your
hands together for the one the only my
man mr. Duke
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside but it's about
to get warm all up in my jazz I of
course Duke silver and I would like to
dedicate this first song to my Duchess
[Music]
you're so lucky I'm going to kill you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen mr. Duke
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you